were you just playing with your dog yeah
she was chewing up on you frisbee so now
i've given her mousse instead
i've got her a new little muscle that's
willow she's there yeah yeah yeah
follow me on instagram no
you follow willow on instagram really
she has more uh she gets a lot more love
than me than i do these days
well look just to give you a quick quick
glance let's see there she is
say hello yes that's that's
uh i got to give me a second before i
readjust this bad boy uh ross confirmed
are we
am i in the right place here mate
yeah you look good yeah okay perfect
i'll take your word for it
no you look good i'm not an expert but
you can blame me
um so this movie was so much fun but i
do want to know on a scale of one to ten
how evil
is your character 10 being like lord
voldemort evil
well i mean he's a 10 in his own realm
the wizarding world is slightly
different um
and also you know voldemort sort of like
the uh the darth vader isn't he
the ultimate darkness this one um
he's he's pretty bad he's the boogeyman
he snatches kids you know it is uh
but he is also quite playful um i think
he is really creepy in many many ways
but he's also kind of a bit of fun i
think
especially as it doesn't always go to
plan
for him um voldemort i think probably
executed his plan slightly better than
the grand gino no you definitely had
some funny lines which i was
it was really fun to watch you kind of
transform into this character
um how much fun was it for you
physically to get into this character
because you were creepy
i love the teeth the teeth are creepy so
they have to be kept painted every
bloody two minutes yeah
it was it was it was so much fun it was
so much fun so
rachel the director she actually
produced a film called the borrowers
which is the first one that i ever did
when i was seven years old
so this was like a really lovely reunion
between us and um
yeah she kind of gave me a license to to
go pretty crazy with it and
uh it took a few weeks but with the
costume department and the fantastic
hair makeup we tried some pretty
wacky stuff uh and ended up with this
brilliant
character i couldn't walk when i was in
that ghetto
you just sort of saunter and slide and
glide everywhere
it's really yeah it really was very
transformative
i love that um now we also got to hear a
little bit of your
singing chops in this your character
seems a bit of a lullaby
yeah you have been entertaining people
on social media with your music and your
guitar
how cool is it that you're bringing so
much joy to people especially during
this time with
your music i mean it's awesome it's
great i mean
that wasn't something that i really
thought about when i signed on to
babysitters but
we spent a couple of days in um in a
recording studio in vancouver with a
whole
bunch of suits important people from
netflix and we went when we
recorded we recorded all these different
versions of songs and i've never done
that before
for a job so that was um a heck of a lot
of fun i'm pretending to be
uh um quite strict and professional the
whole time and inside i was just
giggling like a little girl
um but yeah but yeah it's it's a great
thing i love i love my music so much and
it's i've always done it for fun and
i seem to be getting a warm response
from people online so yeah i
i find it great fun um and are you
loving draco talk videos because you're
responding to this
huge viral trend on tick tock of people
making these
first videos about draco malfoy i mean
are you having a blast because we're
having fun watching you react
i am having more fun on social media
than i've ever had in my life
this came out of nowhere i mean anyone
would tell you i'm not exactly mr tech
savvy
but a very good friend of mine is also
one of the oldest fans i've
had for a long time she she recommended
it to me
and then uh yeah she kind of taught me
the ropes a little bit and then suddenly
we're off to the races with all this
other stuff but i really really uh
i really enjoy it and i've got a feeling
that we're just sort of getting started
really
yeah no they're so fun now this is
completely going to
a whole other level of emotion you let
me know if i'm asking too much but um
obviously it's it's been all over you
know headlines
with the backlash jk rowling has
received over comments she's made about
the trans community i'm just wondering
what
your reaction to that was i don't have a
reaction to that i'm afraid i'm not like
i said not mr social affair i didn't
even know that that was a
a thing and lord knows uh i'm the last
person that's going to wade in on
opinions about what other people have
said
i'll just uh i'll keep looking after
willow and loving everyone that i
can i don't have any uh i don't have any
room for hate in my heart not after
playing the gg for so long and that guy
was evil enough
so now i uh now it's just now it's just
tom the lover so
he's in love that was a perfect answer
thank you so much
it was so nice to talk to you in willow
thanks for your time all right
i'll see you on draco talk